here now the latest on the corona virus  pandemic hospitalizations in Nevada  significantly up right now 849 patients  are hospitalized or diagnosed with or  suspected to have kovat 19 that's a  hundred one more cases than yesterday  again these are hospitalizations the  number of ICU patients is also up 35 new  cases reported from yesterday 236 of  those patients are currently in the ICU  intensive care 112 people are on  ventilators across the state there are  more than 23 thousand cases and 548  deaths from the corona virus Clark  County itself has more than 19,000 cases  you see the numbers on your screen 450  people have died 60 percent of people  who have köppen 19 here in Nevada have  recovered